You will do quite a bit of network
troubleshooting when you're trying to
determine why the network is slow, why
someone's not able to start a particular
application, or why their network
connection simply isn't working as you
would expect. Whenever you sit down at
someone's computer, there may be a very
different network configuration than
someone else's computer. So, it's useful
to run a utility to see how this
particular system is set up. The command
you want to use in Windows is IP config.
This will tell you information about IP
addressing, subnet masks, gateways, and
other information that's important when
troubleshooting the network. The IP
config command can also tell you
information about the network adapter
you're using. So whether you're on a
wired Ethernet connection or a wireless
link, you can get more information about
your network interface card using IP
config. And of course, you may want to
know what DNS servers are configured on
this device. Did this device receive a
DHCP address and from what DHCP server
and other important network details? IP
config can give you this information and
a lot more. Let's say Rodney has asked
us to stop by his computer and perform
some diagnostics. Before we start making
any changes, let's see how this
particular system is configured. We will
run simply the IP config command. This
tells us that we are on an Ethernet
network. gives us IPv6 address
information, IPv4 information, subnet
masks, and default gateway details. But
if we'd like more information, we can
run the same IP config command with the
slashall option. And this provides us
with a great deal of additional
information such as the host name, DNS
suffix information, the type of IP
routing configurations are on this
system. We have information here about
DNS servers that are configured and we
can see here that DHCP is enabled and
that we have not configured an IP
address using DHCP on the system. This
gives us a great deal of information
about how this system has been
configured and what those individual
settings might be.
When you're troubleshooting network
connectivity issues, one of the first
things you'd like to know is if the
machine you're trying to connect to is
really connected to the network. One of
the ways you could do that is by using
the ping command. The ping command tests
reachability by sending a special packet
to a device and getting a response back
from that device. It uses a protocol
known as the internet control message
protocol or MP.
Let's say in this case we'd like to know
if Rodney's machine is really able to
communicate to his primary DNS server.
If we look at the results of our IP
config command, we can see that the
primary DNS server is 192.168.1.155.
So we will use the ping command and
we'll specify 192.168.155
and we can see that we have connectivity
to that device. We ping that device with
32 bytes of data and it got four
separate replies back from that device.
This also tells us response time
information for receiving that response
from that particular IP address and it
provides time to live information as
well. We'll talk more about time to live
in just a moment. Now we've got a
summary of all of the pings that we ran.
By default we sent four pings. We
received four back which means there was
0% loss and we can see the approximate
roundtrip times minimum are 5
milliseconds. maximum is 322
milliseconds, which means the average is
143 milliseconds. Based on this
information, we can determine if we
really are able to reach that particular
device, and we can get information about
how well and how quickly we're able to
send and receive information to that
server. Our local computers are
constantly communicating across the
network to other servers and there may
be times that other devices are
communicating to your device to gather
information as well. One way that you
can see these connections is by using
the netstat command. Netstat stands for
network statistics and it's a command
that's used in Windows, Linux, Mac OS,
and other operating systems. The default
netstack command can tell you a lot of
information about the communication
occurring across the network, but there
are some options you might want to try
to give you some additional details. For
example, netstat- a will show you all
active connections on a Windows machine.
If you're interested in knowing exactly
which Windows binary was used to be able
to send or receive this network
communication, you can use netstat-b.
If you are going to use that command,
you will need to run in an elevated mode
or run as an administrator at the
command prompt. By default, netstat will
try to perform DNS resolution so you can
see the fully qualified domain name
instead of IP addresses. But if you'd
rather see the IP address, you can use
the dash option to only show IP in the
netstat output.
Let's run the netstat command on
Rodney's machine. We'll run netstat
without any other options and just see
what we get. You can see there's a
column for protocol. In this case, it
would be TCP or UDP. There are local
addresses and port numbers that are
mentioned. There also foreign addresses.
This is the other device that we are
communicating with that is different
than the local address. And then there
is a state for that communication.
Sometimes we are established, others
might say close wait. There may be other
statistics that you'd see depending on
the status of that network. connection
to get an idea of how things might
change with network communication. Let's
start up a browser communication using
Chrome. It loaded up the Google
homepage. And now let's run that
NetStack command again. You can see
there are a number of new entries in
this netstat table because we initiated
additional network connections to these
servers located at Google. It's
difficult to tell from this view exactly
what applications are associated with
these different connections. So let's
close out that window and open a new
command prompt. But in this case, we're
going to run it as administrator.
Windows now asks for administrator
access so that it can launch that
command prompt with elevated access. We
will use administrator
and I will use the password for the
administrator account on this domain.
And now we have a command prompt that is
running as administrator. Now let's do
the same netstat command. And you can
see there are a number of different
connections that are going back and
forth. Now let's open up our Chrome
browser again and have it launch that
Google screen. And in this case, let's
run a netstat-b.
You'll notice the same connections are
shown, but for every connection, you can
see the executable that's used for that
connection. For example, we have a
number of different connections down
here that are connecting over HTTPS. And
you can see that Chrome.exe exe is the
application that caused that network
communication to occur.
We rely on our domain name servers to be
able to convert from a fully qualified
domain name back to an IP address and we
can also perform an IP address to fully
qualified domain name conversion. We
also can gather a lot more details from
DNS servers and we can use the utility
NS lookup to be able to perform those
queries. There are extensive options
available in the NSOup application.
Although most of the time we're simply
performing a lookup of an IP address or
name. There are many different options
within NSOKUP. And I highly encourage
you to look at some of the other
capabilities. You might end up using
those to troubleshoot a number of
network issues. Let's perform a simple
NSLOP from this machine. Let's see if
we're able to get the IP address of
www.professormemes.com.
So, I'll run nsookup and then I'll
specify www.professor
messor.com.
This will go out to our default DNS
server, which is 192.168.1.155.
And this tells us there are three IP
addresses that are associated with this
fully qualified domain name. There's
104.22.72.108,
104.22.73.108,
and 172.67.41.114.
Normally, we would see a one:one
relationship between the fully qualified
domain name and the IP address, but I
built in additional redundancy into my
network configuration. So, this is not
an unusual response when you're querying
this particular fully qualified domain
name.
Many of the commands that we've done so
far are very specific to TCP IP, but
there are some commands we can run that
gives us information about the Windows
operating system and how it connects to
other devices. The command that we would
commonly use for this is the net command
or NE. There are a few net commands you
should be aware of. One is the net view
command that shows us what shares might
be available on a particular device.
There's the net use command that allows
you to connect to those available
shares. And then there's the net user
command that can be used to view
information about an account and change
passwords associated with that account.
Back on Rodney's machine, we know that
there is a server called Cheyenne 1 and
there are shares on that server, but we
don't remember what those shares are.
So, we're going to use the net view
command with the name of that server.
And we'll use two backslashes to
designate that this is a server name.
Chn1
is the name of that server. And you can
see that there are a number of shares
available. There's the net loon share
and the sysball share. These are common
shares that are built into the Windows
system. But there's also the missions
share and the schematics share. Let's
say that we'd like to connect to the
schematic share. If we were to look at
our system, I'll bring up the file
explorer. We can see that currently we
have a local drive. That's our C drive.
We also have an X drive, a Y drive, and
a Z drive on this system. So, let's now
connect to the schematic share by using
the net use command. For net use, we
need to specify the drive letter that
will be associated with this share.
Let's say that we're going to use H
colon in this example. And then we'll
specify the server name and the name of
the share. The server name has two
backslashes and chy en ne1 and then
another backslash and the name of the
share. In this case, schematics. And if
we hit enter, it says that the command
completed successfully. If we now go
back to our file explorer, we can see
that a new drive share has appeared on
Cheyenne for H colon and it is our
schematics share.
If we're troubleshooting Rodney's
computer, we may want to get more
details about their user account
information. So, we can run the net user
command to provide those details. Let's
specify that this is rm c a y. That's
the username for this user. And let's
also specify that this is going to be
for a domain. If we hit enter, we can
get more details on this username. We
can see the full name for this person.
Information about country codes. Is the
account active? In this case, yes, it
is. When was the password last set? When
does it expire? You got information
about login scripts and login
directories. And information about any
groups this user may be a part of. So,
if you're troubleshooting this
particular user and you want to know
information about what groups they
belong to or how their account is
currently configured, simply use the net
user command.
When we're communicating to another
device on the network, that other device
might be on our local subnet, it might
be in our building, it might be in a
different city or a different country.
One way that you could see all of the
different connections between you and
that other device, is by using the trace
route command, and in Windows, this is
abbreviated trace RT. Trace Route uses
ICMP, which is the same protocol we use
for ping to be able to determine where
all of the different routers might be
between our device and another IP
address. It uses a feature of MP called
time to live exceeded and it uses that
in conjunction with a time to live
setting. In the world of IP version 4,
time to live is not referring to seconds
or minutes or a time of day. It's
referring to a number of hops. A hop is
referred to as a single connection
passing through a router. So a time to
live of one would be your connection to
the first router. Time to live of two
would be able to give you the
information to connect to the second
router and so on. Time to live relies on
MP and the ability to send these MP
messages across the network. Some
firewalls will filter out this ICMP
information, which means you may have
limited visibility when trying to
determine where a particular router
might be. We're going to run a time to
live on Rodney's computer, but before we
do that, let's see what's happening
behind the scenes. This is a setup that
has a couple of computers on our local
network and a device that's on the
remote network. In this scenario, we're
going to run a trace route from Sam's
laptop to Jack's computer. And it's
going to pass through a few switches.
You can see those switches are the
square boxes. And then it's also going
to pass through a number of routers. The
routers are the round icons that you see
on the screen. Each time we hit a
router, that's a hop. And it's going to
specify what the IP address is of that
hop on the local machine. So, for
instance, let's run a trace route to
1010.30.10.
10. Obviously 1010.3010
is Jack's machine here on the remote
network. The first step is Sam will set
up a trace route and it will set a time
to live of one and that will be sent to
the first router that is closest to SAM.
That first router sees that time to live
is equal to one. And one of the
responsibilities of every router is to
decrease time to live by one each time a
packet goes through. So time to live is
going to be changed to zero, which means
the time to live is exceeded. Every time
you hit TTL equals 0, a message is sent
back to the originating station saying,
"Sorry, we weren't able to complete this
because time to live got all the way
down to zero. Your time to live has been
exceeded." When trace route receives
that TTL exceeded message, it puts a
message up on the screen that says, "Our
first router is 1010.10.1 10.1 because
that's the device that sent back that
time to live exceeded message. Now the
process repeats but instead of sending
it out as a time to live equal to one,
the time to live will be equal to two.
When it hits the first router, the time
to live will be decreased by one. So
time to live is now one. Then it goes to
the next router and time to live is
decreased one more time down to zero.
Time to live has been exceeded and that
message is sent back to Sam's
workstation and the results are put on
the screen. Process happens again where
time to live is now set to three. This
goes to the first router where time to
live will go from 3 to two. Goes to the
second router where time to live goes
from 2 to 1 and then goes to the third
router where time to live hits zero.
Time to live is exceeded. That message
is sent back to Sam's workstation and
the results of that are put on the
screen. This process will continue until
we finally make it to that end device of
1010.3010.
So now time to live is incremented up to
four. That means it goes to the first
router and decreases to three. Goes to
the second router, goes down to two,
goes to the third router, TTL goes down
to one, and then finally makes it to
Jack's workstation. and Jack now is able
to send back a reply to that message
saying that it made it all the way
through from Sam's machine to Jack's
machine. The results of that are also
put on the screen and we now have our
trace route showing all four hops
between Sam's machine and Jack's
machine. Here's an example of a trace
route. This trace route is to 99.9.
It takes a few seconds for trace route
to run. This is the result of a trace
route that I did to 99.99.9.
It says that it's doing this to DNS9.
9.net, which is the DNS name associated
with 9.9.9.9.
And you can see there are eight
different hops that occurred to get from
my machine, which is 10.110.1,
all the way down to 99.9.
And you can see with each one of these,
there are three different attempts that
were made. And in each attempt, we're
able to receive information about
response time for each one of these
hops. We also have IP addresses and
names associated with each router along
the way. So, we know that 10.110.1
communicates to 96.12058.37.
The next router in these hops is
96.110.208.117
and so on. We can track every hop along
the way to determine exactly what
routers are involved with this
communication. If we run into problems
on the network, we can run this trace
route again and compare the results we
got originally with the new set of
results. For example, if a router in the
middle of the conversation was to fail,
even though that router is in a
different city or a different state, we
still know what IP address was supposed
to be there, and we can show that this
is the normal route versus the route
that we're seeing now.
These ping functions and trace route
utilities are incredibly useful when
you're troubleshooting the network. But
what if you could combine the features
of ping and trace route into a single
utility? That utility is path ping and
this is a utility commonly found on most
versions of Windows. Pathping has two
different phases that it goes through.
The first phase is that it runs a trace
route to build out a map of the
connection between your device and the
destination IP address. On the second
phase, it then runs a roundtrip test to
each of those hops. So now we're able to
get a better understanding of the
performance from our device to each
router on every hop from our device to
another. Here's an example where I ran a
path ping to 8.8.8.8.
And you can see the first thing that it
does is run a trace route. This is a
very similar view to what we saw when
running an independent trace RT utility
command. This is one that shows us all
of the different hops. And you can see
there are 13 hops to reach 8.8.8. at
8.8. This is the output from the first
phase of the path ping command. Once it
understands what all of these different
hops are, it will then start computing
statistics for each one of those routers
along the way. And you can see here that
Pathping says it's going to calculate
statistics for 325
seconds. Once those 325 seconds have
elapsed, Pathping then presents you with
information about every hop, the amount
of roundtrip time between each one of
those. We can see how many packets have
been sent and how many were lost along
the way. And we can see information
about the addresses at each one of these
hops. Most of these work flawlessly, but
you can see there must be a firewall at
hop 12 or some type of filter because we
weren't able to get response time
statistics from that particular IP
address.